Luke Cage: "My Name is Luke Cage."
If you're like me and you binge-watched all thirteen episodes of Luke Cage, your brain is probably mush.
Along with forgetting to feed yourself, you probably missed these references.
Here are our top five favorite easter eggs from Luke Cage.
Number 5: Stan Lee's Cameo
Lee's face can be seen on a poster in the twelfth episode opf Luke Cage.
When Luke stop a robbery and runs into Method Man.
There you see Stan,
Dressed as a police officer, urging citizens to report any crimes they may see.
Also, Luke and Method swap sweatshirts.
Besties!
Number 4: Colleen Wing
In episode thirteen, Claire Temple finds a flier for Martial arts training by Colleen Wing.
In the Comics, Colleen is Misty Knight’s partner in Heroes for Hire,
a group started by Luke Cage.
She is also friends with Luke Cage’s partner and the next Marvel hero to get his own show,
Danny Rand, or Iron Fist.
Number Three: Power Man
Power Man is the moniker Luke Cage decides to go by after being in the hero game for a while
and realizing he needs to up his brand.
Pop calls him this in what sounds like an inside joke. We get it Pop.
Pop: "Not a problem for you, Power Man"
Number Two:  Back to the Future
In Episode 10, Misty Knight is looking at microfiche (I love that word) newspaper records
or Carl Lucas, Luke Cage’s name from before he gained powers.
She finds the article she needs and the article we all want.
An obvious homage to Back to the Future with changes to prevent copyright issues.
Martian Brown and Mac Fly are referenced as well as a “Thrust Capacitor”.
Dr. Brown: "Roads? Where we're going we don't need roads."
Number One: The Classic Cage Costume
This is an obvious one for comic book readers.
After escaping from Seagate Prison with his fashionable tiara and cuffs,
Cage comes across a baggy yellow shirt.
It's a wierd moment for comic book readers.
Cage looks at his reflection for 30 seconds and realizes what we've all known for 30 years.
He looks rediculous.
Luke Cage: "You look like a damn fool."
Sometimes the comic books just don’t translate to the screen but
kudos to the producers for throwing it in there for us.
For more on your favorite comic books, TV and movies, checkout Gamespot Universe.